How concerned should we be very
concerned I mean this is something that
the committee has been looking at for
some time huge investments in the last
couple of decades into Maritime
capability into the aircraft carriers
into the RAF with the typhoon and indeed
the F-35 but the Army is in a dire State
you have three main components to land
warfare that's your tank your main
battle tank your armored fighting
vehicle and your recce vehicle and in
our case you have the Challenger 2 you
have the warrior and you have the
scimiter and they're all over 20 30 or
50 years old without any upgrades and
I'm pleased that voices are now coming
through to say this is unacceptable
we've whittled down our capability we
had 900 tanks a couple decades we're now
looking down going down to 148 and as we
see in Ukraine tanks are still required
on the modern battlefield but that's the
thing isn't it up until now we had
thought that the modern Battlefield
would be uh in in space rather than um
on the ground who's the we there that
was the last defense review where there
was a tilt absolutely right to invest in
cyber and space security we need to do
that because this is a new advance in
the character of conflict but that
doesn't mean you do it at the cost of
your land forces and our army is simply
too small we've cut down by 10 000
troops I do hope that the the defense
review refresh as it's being called will
you know look at these issues and
reverse some of the swathing cuts that
we saw uh that were made a couple years
ago
um the defense secretary of he was
sitting here would tell me that we are
the biggest investor in defense in
Europe that is correct we have nuclear
deterrent which costs a lot of money he
has done an excellent job in ramping up
The Replacements to all these but they
won't come in our new battle tank the
Challenger 3 won't be completed until
2030. likewise with the uh the recce
vehicle the Ajax has had so many
problems might actually be cut
completely and then the Warrior fighting
vehicle which is what I used in Bosnia
and places like that has a brilliant
turret on the top of it being replaced
by boxer which is a wheel vehicle and it
doesn't even have a big firing
capability on the top of it there's no
turret so he's I think concerned about
this wants to address this but
ultimately it's up to the treasury it's
up to number 10 to recognize the world
is changing we are now at war in Europe
we need to move to a war footing we are
involved in that we've mobilized our
procurement processes we're gifting
equipment we need to face Russia
directly and reckon rather than leaving
Ukraine to do all the work how
vulnerable are we well on many occasions
we have to ask ourselves what is that
threat if we see Russia wanting to do
more things in the baltics for example
there have been expectation indeed
anticipation that we would participate
in that that requires land forces air as
well and not and Maritime too and we've
whittled it down over the last couple of
decades we've become complacent so yes
we're unable to meet all the task Kings
on top of that you have domestic issues
as well when there's flooding when
there's covert who do we lean on to jump
in it's the armed forces and they're
getting very very tired of what they're
doing we need to invest to make sure
that we you know retain people the good
people that are there I have to say
they're the most professional in the
world as to what they do but there's
simply not enough of them and the
equipment is now obsolete we're only
three hours away from war in Europe as I
found out when I went to Ukraine last
week and yet this government seems to be
absolutely mired in challenges about the
chairman and his tax Affairs the Deputy
Prime Minister and whether he's a bully
or not what are you going to do with
this party well let's keep that in
perspective because it is these bigger
issues that we need to be concerned
about the cost of living crisis here is
caused in part by what's going on in
Ukraine the oil and gas prices they've
calmed down a bit but they could easily
Spike too but the the cost of food going
up in here that's because something that
you and I have discussed many times here
is because the grain isn't leaving
Odessa I want us to focus on these
things these are the things that would
help our economy these are the things
that will help the British people we
need to make it clear the connection
between our security and our economy and
indeed our prosperity they are not two
separate things you happy with Nadine
zaha we're sitting on the back benches
with you uh you know no I'll say Nadeem
has been one of my closest friends in
Parliament I'm very saddened by what's
happened he was a very effective uh
chairman he clearly thought that uh when
it was labeled as careless rather than
deliberate his his his tax returns with
hmrc that he could write this through uh
prime minister I think rightly had a
review of this because it became you
know this dominating issue nobody could
go into an interview studio and not be
asked about it when you get to that
point then the Prime Minister has to act
so he called this review he got the
results and he's acted okay it's always
great to see Mr Elwood thank you very
much indeed thank you